>>> ALSO THIS MORNING, PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAMMERING FLORIDA SENATOR
RICK SCOTT AND HIS PROPOSAL TO
SUNSET ALL FEDERAL LEGISLATION
AFTER GIVE YEARS, INCLUDING
MEDICARE AND SOCIAL SECURITY
UNLESS CONGRESS DECIDED TO
REAUTHORIZE IT.
SCOTT DEFENDED THE PROPOSAL HE
MADE YESTERDAY COMPARING IT TO A
2017 REPUBLICAN HEALTH CARE PLAN
THAT WOULD HAVE CUT INSURANCE
FROM 24 MILLION AMERICANS
ACCORDING TO THE CFO.
HE BROUGHT UP AN INTERVIEW WITH
MY COLLEAGUE JAKE TAPPER PRESSED
A TRUMP OFFICIAL ON THE CUTS.
>> LET ME READ YOU SOMETHING
JAKE TAPPER SAID.
THIS IS BACK WHEN REPUBLICANS
WERE PROPOSING REDUCING THE
COST.
WHAT JAKE TAPPER SAID.
AND JAKE TAPPER SAID THAT IS A
CUT.
IF YOU TALK TO JAKE TAPPER, WHY
DID HE SAY IT WAS A CUT IF
REPUBLICANS DO IT?
DID THE SAME FACT-CHECKERS LOOK
AT WHAT JAKE TAPPER SAID?
WHY DIDN'T JAKE TAPPER SAY THAT
$880 BILLION CUT IN MEDICAID IS
A CUT.
IT'S GOING TO REDUCE LIFE-SAVING
DRUGS.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU SAY IT HAS
AN IMPACT ON DRUGS.
THAT IS DIFFERENT THOUGH THAN
SAYING THAT THEY CUT MEDICARE
WHEN THEY ARE SAVING MONEY ON
THE COST OF WHAT THOSE DRUGS
COST TO AMERICANS.
>> OKAY.
BUT THEN WHAT -- WHY DID JAKE
TAPPER SAY THAT $880 BILLION CUT
IN MEDICAID IS A CUT.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
DEFENSE THAT YOU THINK IT IS.
>> HERE IS WHAT JAKE ACTUALLY
SAID.
>> ACCORDING TO THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE, THE
HEALTH CARE BILL THAT PASSED THE
HOUSE WOULD CUT $880 BILLION
OVER TEN YEARS FROM MEDICAID.
I KNOW THAT THE TRUMP-
ADMINISTRATION IS EXCITED
MEDICAID WILL GO BACK TO THE
STATES WHERE THEY CAN HAVE MORE
CONTROL AND BE MORE EFFICIENT.
WITHOUT QUESTION 880 BILLION
FEWER DOLLARS IS A CUT.
>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS IS
CNN'S JAKE TAPPER.
JAKE, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT,
WATCHING THAT INTERVIEW, HEARING
YOUR NAME BE INVOKED SO MANY
TIMES BY SENATOR SCOTT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, ROUGH MORNING
FOR ANYBODY THAT WAS PLAYING THE
JAKE TAPPER DRINKING GAME FOR
EIGHT TIMES IN FIVE MINUTES.
TEN MINUTES.
THAT'S -- FIRST, IT WAS
INCOMPREHENSIBLE, TO BE HONEST.
THERE ARE SO MANY ISSUES HERE.
ONE IS SENATOR RICK SCOTT
PROPOSED SUN SETTING ALL FEDERAL
PROGRAMS EVERY FIVE YEARS AND IF
THEY ARE WORTHWHILE, CONGRESS
CAN RENEW HIM.
THAT'S HIS PROPOSAL.
JUST IN THE LAST DAY, THE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER MITCH McCONNELL
WAS SAYING THAT IS THE RICK
SCOTT PLAN, NOT THE REPUBLICAN
PLAN.
AND HOW SPEAKER McCARTHY HAS
BEEN SAYING THE SAME THING.
THAT'S NOT OR PLAN.
RICK SCOTT D PROPOSE IT AND HE
WAS THE HEAD OF THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN SENATORIAL COMMITTEE
WHEN HE PROPOSED IT.
THAT'S A FACT.
FOR WHATEVER REASON, SENATOR
SCOTT DIDN'T WANT TO STAND BY
THAT PLAN.
AND THERE IS A WAY TO DISCUSS
IT.
YOU CAN SAY MEDICARE AND SOCIAL
SECURITY THEY ARE REALLY ISSUES
WITH SOLVENCY AND THIS IS A WAY
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION, ET
CETERA.
BY ALL MEANS, THEY SHOULD HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION.
JUST THE WHATEVER THAT WAS, THAT
WORD SALAD WHERE HE KEPT
MENTIONING ME WAS VERY STRANGE
TO ME.
HE WAS TRYING TO COMPARE
MEDICARE NOW BEING ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE DRUG PRICES WITH DRUG
COMPANIES, WHICH IS NOT A CUT
FROM MEDICARE.
IT'S A CUT IN PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANY PROFITS, WITH ME ASKING
A QUESTION ABOUT THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE
ANALYSIS OF A MEDICATE BILL FROM
SELF?
IT'S NONSENSICAL.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
HE DIDN'T SAY JAKE TAPPER SAYS
WHEN HE DID HIS INTERVIEW ON
FOX.
ACCIDENT SAY JAKE TAPPER SAYS
WHEN HE DID HIS INTERVIEWS OVER
PLACES.
SOMEONE GAVE HIM THAT TALK
POINT, THEY SAID IT ON CNN, JAKE
TAPPER SAYS IT, WHATEVER.
HE WAS USING THAT AS A TALKING
POINT AND KIND OF A GOTCHA TO
CNN DURING KAITLIN'S INTERVIEW.
SHE IS RIGHT, IT'S NOT THE
DEFENSE YOU THINK IT IS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
BUT I THINK, OBVIOUSLY, IT FELL
FLAT.
>> YEAH, NO, LOOK, WHEN HE WENT
ON FOX NOT THIS WEEK BUT
RECENTLY TO TRY TO DEFEND THIS
RESCUE AMERICA PLAN, HE ACCUSED
FOX OF READING DEMOCRATIC
TALKING POINTS.
>> JOHN ROBERTS IN THE SUMMER.
>> YEAH.
AND ALL JOHN WAS DOING WAS
LITERALLY READING THE RICK SCOTT
PLAN.
SO, LOOK, I'M NOT HERE -- AND
THE AS ALL OF YOU.
I AM NOT HERE TO TAKE A POSITION
ON HIS PLAN.
THIS IS HIS PLAN.
I AM NOT PRO RICK SCOTT PLAN.
I AM NOT ANTI-RICK SCOTT PLAN.
HERE IS WHAT HE IS PROPOSING.
OBVIOUSLY, HE DOESN'T WANT TO
DEFEND IT.
HE WANTS TO CHANGE THE SUBJECT,
WHICH IS ODD, BUT THAT'S ALSO
HIS PREROGATIVE.
>> WE NEED MORE OF JAKE TAPPER
IN THE MORNING ON THIS PROGRAM.
I AM NOT SURE THAT'S THE WAY WE
WANTED TO GET IT.
WE ARE GLAD TO GOT YOU HERE.
I WANT YOUR TAKE ON WHAT MITCH
McCONNELL SAID IN THE LAST 24
HOURS.
HERE IT IS.
>> THIS DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH THAT.
IT'S A BAD IDEA.
I THINK IT WILL BE A CHALLENGE
FOR HIM TO DEAL WITH THIS AS ALL
RE-ELECTION IN FLORIDA, MORE
ELDERLY PEOPLE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN AMERICA.
>> THAT IS REALLY INTERESTING TO
HEAR McCONNELL SAY.
OBVIOUSLY, NO LOVE LOST BETWEEN
THE TWO.
TO HEAR HIM SAY THIS IS GOING TO
MAKE HIS RE-ELECTION IN HIS
STATE HARDER, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, RICK
SCOTT HAS BEEN CHALLENGING MITCH
McCONNELL FOR THE LEADERSHIP
POSITION IN THE SENATE.
HE HAS FAILED.
HE HAS NOT SUCCESSFULLY
CHALLENGED HIM.
HE HAS BEEN TRYING TO DO IT.
SECOND OF ALL, I THINK THAT THIS
IS EXACTLY WHY, THE WAY THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS USING THIS
ISSUE, IS EXACTLY WHY SO MANY
REPUBLICANS DID NOT EMBRACE THE
RICK SCOTT PLAN BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS ELECTORALLY
POLITICALLY A REAL
VULNERABILITY.
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION THAT THERE
ARE SOME REPUBLICANS PRO POING
SUN SETTING MEDICARE AND SOCIAL
SECURITY, IT'S ACCURATE.
RICK SCOTT PROPOSED IT.
NOW, ALL THE REPUBLICANS THAT
BOOED HIM AND CALLED HIM A LIAR,
THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
RICK SCOTT DID PROPOSE IT.
DID THE TRUTH IS WHAT McCONNELL
SAID, RICK SCOTT PROPOSED IT BUT
MOST REPUBLICANS HAVE DISTANCED
THEMSELVES FROM IT QUITE A BIT.
>> McCONNELL IS LIKE, OWE'RE TH
LEADERS OF THE PARTY IN OUR
REPRESENTATIVE CHAMBERS.
WE ARE AGAINST THIS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT.
WE HEARD REPUBLICANS SAY THAT.
I WILL SAY, YOU KNOW, TO BE FAIR
TO RICK SCOTT, HIS SENIOR
ADVISOR TO HIM IN RESPONDING TO
McCONNELL SAID RICK SCOTT KNOWS
HOW TO WIN FLORIDA A HELL OF A
LOT BETTER THAN MITCH McCONNELL
DOES.
THEY CAN KEEP PARROTING
DEMOCRATIC LIES.
HE WON'T STOP FIGHTING FOR
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES.
HE IS STANDING BY THIS PLAN.
WHEN I ASKED HIM IF IT WAS A
MISTAKE HE SAID, NO, HE DIDN'T
THINK IT WAS A MISTAKE TO
PROPOSE IT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, JAKE, YOU HAVE
A VERY IMPORTANT --
>> WHO KNOWS HOW TO WIN ON
SUNDAY, RIGHT?
>> WHO ARE YOU ROOTING FOR?
>> THE GREEN TIE.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE CAN'T TELL.
>> SO THERE IS -- THIS IS MY
EAGLES TIE.
AND THIS IS FROM THE LAST TIME
THEY WON THE SUPER BOWL.
AND WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
ANOTHER VICTORY THIS SUNDAY.
THE BELOVED PHILADELPHIA EAGLES.
I KNOW WE ARE UNDERDOGS AGAINST
THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS FOR WHOM
MY WIFE ROOTS.
>> OOH!
>> BUT IT'S GOING TO BE A GOOD
GAME.
I WILL SAY IT'S MUCH MORE FUN TO
ROOT AGAINST THE VILLAINOUS
PATRIOTS THAN IT IS AGAINST THE
CHIEFS.
THEY ARE JUST NOT AS, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT LIKE GOING AGAINST THE
DEATH STAR.
BUT I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO A
GOOD GAME AND THE EAGLES BEING
VICTORIOUS.
JALEN HURTS IS A PHENOM.
>> HOW IS IT SLEEPING ON THE
COUCH, JAKE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT'S GOOD.
WE JUST GOT A NEW COACH.
IT'S VERY COMFORTABLE.
>> DON'T ROOT AGAINST JEN
TAPPER.
ALL RIGHT, JAKE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> MY NIMAME FOR JAKE NOW IS JA
TAPPER SAYS.
>> DON'T DO THE DRINKING GAME
WHEN RICK SCOTT IS ON.
>> THANKS, JAKE.